فلازمك اقتصاديه والسيجار
اللبناني
هو الاول عالميا باستهلاك السجائر الفاخره
كما نعلم ان السيجار هو من احد مظاهر
الطرف
حديثه تبين ان لبنان يتصدر لائحه دول ثريه
يتفوق فيها على امريكا التي احتلت المرتبه
الثانيه وقطر في المرتبه الثالثه يعني هذه
الارقام اثارت موجه من السخريه في الشارع
اللبناني وموجه ايضا من التساؤلات فكيف
يمكن يعني للمواطن اللبناني الذي يرزح جزء
كبير منهم من اجل احتياجاتهم اليوميه ان
ينفقوا ما ينفقوه على السيجار الفاخر في
وقت يرى مراقبون عادل وراويه انه سلوك
لبناني هو الذي اختلف خلال هذه الازمه
فاصبح اللبناني لم يعد يدخر ماله فما يفيض
له من اموال على ما يبدو ينفقه على
الكماليات وعقارات وسيجار من باب نفخ
عليها تنجلي ومن باب كمان للناس فيما
يعشقون مذاهبه
طيب موضوعنا الثاني ياري
نا اسقطوا في طرابلس شو القصه مين ابو
الفقراء اصلا
ايه صحيح راويه يعني من يعرف طرابلس جيدا
ويعرف سوق الشعبي يعرف نضال عبد الهادي او
ابو الفقراء يعني هذا الرجل كان يبسط
بسطته هنا لاكثر من اربعين عام يعني لا
يمكن ان تمر من جانب هذه البسطه دون ان
تستوصفك لانه كان يبيع السكان اوروبيه
جديده ومستعمله باسعار رمزيه وتلامس
الخيال في بعض الاحيان وكانت له يعني نوع
من التجاره الغريبه على هذه المصالح
التجاريه يعني يوزع كانه بالمجان وله
عباره شهيره تقول اذا ما معك مصاري خذوا
الله معك نضال عبد الهادي غادر هذه البسطه
هنا ترك يعني باع بسطته وباع معها احلام
الكثيرين من من محدودي الدخل بقطعه جديده
على قدر
قدرتهم فبالتالي يعني هذا المكان سيشكل
فرقا هنا خاصه وان حتى البضائع المستعمله
اصبحت خارج قدره الكثيرين ابو الفقراء
للامانه انا التقيت في الصبح ولكنه يعني
رفض امام الكاميرا كان هنا ليلقي السلام
على احد زملائه هنا لانه يعني قال لي انه
لم يخطط لاي شيء بعد ولكنه ترك شقفه من
قلبه كما نقول هنا في هذا المكان يعني كل
التوفيق لابو الفقراء شكرا جزيلا لك رينا
دويهي من لبنان لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات